[Music]
tim tebow fever is still growing people
are
yeah
a lot of people are
yay boo yay boo it's lots of fun to do
do you like it haul or yay if you don't
you holler boo
that was worse than the beatboxing you
just you just became your mother
[Laughter]
no team tebow fever this is it's growing
it is people are fascinated with this
guy now lots of people are jumping on
the tim tebow bandwagon for example this
is a true story there's this singer
named john parr
who had a hit in the 1980s
with the title song from the movie saint
elmo's fire okay
he just i'm not lying he just
re-released that song with different
lyrics and he's calling it tim tebow's
fire
i'm not making this up check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
and i guess it's working because it's
becoming kind of a hit on the internet
she's freaking me out well guess what we
looked into it this is not the first
time this guy's tried to get some
attention by using a news story to
revise his one hit check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah then there's this one
it's my favorite infomercial
[Music]
another one
i can send it on
[Music]
[Applause]
you just can't put fire at the end of
things